James Chase author of 1912 I want to
read a quote from your book from Woodrow
Wilson after Versailles after the World
War one if I didn't feel that I was a
personal instrument of God I couldn't
carry on sounded all like today it
sounds very much like today in fact I
think what we're seeing when the Bush
administration actually isn't what I
would call Neil Sounion ISM a latter-day
wilsonian ISM in which the President and
I think also feels very much that he is
doing what is the death in his destiny
that God has given him to fulfill which
is very similar to what Woodrow Wilson
believed at Versailles so it is is the
Bush administration Wilsonian all
through and what was that what does that
mean well it's it's I think it's
certainly certainly true in in the White
House and among the people around the
president known as the neoconservatives
they have a very strong belief that you
should impose democracy in other parts
of the world which was very much a
Wilsonian view this time however it's a
military imposition of democracy and
it's very questionable whether that
would work it seems to me if Woodrow
Wilson was here today what party would
he be in that's a good question I think
probably Ronnie might very well be in
the Republican Party that sense although
his domestic policy was very different
from the Republican Party today which is
basically Conservative Party and the
conservative wing of the party it very
much has power so Wilson would would
have to straddle I guess in what we say
nowadays you'd have to straddle
now if Theodore Roosevelt in your book
was here today what party would he be
he'd be John McCain basically and McCain
is a tremendous admirer of Theodore
Roosevelt Roosevelt was a again very
radical domestic policy quite amazingly
amazingly so his platform in 1912 was
probably the most radical platform
perhaps any major candidate for the
major political parties ever run on he
was not only for having a graduated
income tax and to have inheritance tax
but also to have women women's suffrage
which was not popular among politicians
at that time and even a national kind of
national health care policy was quite a
amazingly rad
platform Ulsan one who was for the idea
back then of electing presidents
I mean senators directly well the city
and under the Wilson administration
first Wilson administration the election
of direct senators directly rather than
by khaleja Slater's was passed you see
what's interesting is that in 1912 the
spirit of reform was so strong in the
United States that the Progressive Party
which was then zero Roosevelt's after he
split the Republican Party to form his
own party he Roosevelt and Wilson had
had a very very strong Reformers both of
them Wilson came rather late to reform
and if someone who said he was rather
opportunistic but nonetheless it was
informant and in his first
administration Wilson passed tremendous
amount of liberal legislation some
things I just mentioned also however a
the Federal Reserve Bank which is a
Federal Reserve Bank which is a very
important active Federal Reserve Act
because up to that point private bank is
notably JP Morgan and really run the
monetary policy United States a private
banker and that changed dramatically the
way monetary policy should be run in
this country so you could smooth out
those ups and downs of monetary policy
by intervention by the Federal Reserve
rather than by an a private banker
bailing out the country which as I say
JP Morgan did very effectively in
nineteen seven if Eugene debb's another
subject in your book was here today what
party would he be in who would he be
well gene Debs would not have the party
exactly he'd be very comfortable in you
some people might have suggests he'd be
sort of a Ralph Nader but I but again it
the strong thing about Deb's was his
real strong belief in unionism he'd be
on the left wing I think of the of the
of the Democratic Party today I would
take the left wing the Democratic Party
president William Howard Taft your
fourth subject William Howard Taft was a
moderate conservative he wasn't he
wasn't a like there's a little more
extreme conservatives today in the
Republican Party who tend to be very
moralistic for example among other
things and wanting to very much
oftentimes it seems to be to turn back
the clock to a pre New Deal period
Taft was a moderate conservatives he
believed that you should control big
business when it was out of hand but
judicial means in other words he didn't
like to have a lot of legislation but
yet nonetheless when he was present he
brought more antitrust suits than his
predecessor Theodore Roosevelt but
always based on the notion that they
were doing something illegal it was
illegal and very much of a legalist he
always wanted to be a Supreme Court
justice and in fact after 1921 he became
a Supreme Court justice with which it
was what he always wanted even was very
happy in that role which book is this
for you how many I kept though I think
at eight or nine I guess what was the
last one last was a biography of Dean
Acheson how did that do it good very I
think it did quite well as a matter of
fact and why 1912 what when you remember
when you got interested in this election
I got interested in it for for a
backwards reason I spent my whole life
pretty much writing about foreign policy
and most the jobs I've held have been in
foreign policy field one point is
management of foreign affairs magazine
etc and what began to interest me with
the what ifs of history
what if Theodore Roosevelt had been
elected president in 1912 and then later
on I began to find out even more about
it and saw that he might have been
elected in 1916 and that he would have
been elected in 1928 he lived three
things happen in 1912 his chosen heir
William Howard Taft who was a good
friend of his it was a kind of
lieutenant Taft was always a better
lieutenant than captain in that sense
Roosevelt put him in in nineteen eight
after he finished his two terms as
president I mean he was he was his
anointed heir and he expected that Taft
would carry out his policies which were
formless policies not as extreme as he
was in 1912 but still a reformist
President Taft probably wanted to do
that but Taft was not a good politician
and he didn't know how to manage the
arch conservatives of the Republican
Party then under the control of Senator
Nelson Aldrich of Rhode Island who was
considered to be the the manager of the
United States what happened and in short
though
was that Roosevelt feeling that he that
the Taft had betrayed his policies
decided to run against him for the
Republican nomination it was the very
beginning of the primary system in this
country direct primaries and Roosevelt
ran of the primaries and got actually
more delegates coming to convention the
William Howard Taft
but the machinery of the Republican
Party disqualified many of Theodore
Roosevelt's 80 of Theodore Roosevelt's
delegates and basically handed the
nomination to William Howard Taft so
Roosevelt joined a new party and
immobilizer called the Progressive Party
now had Roosevelt won the Republican
nomination and not formed a third party
he would almost surely have become
president United States it was enormous
ly popular and the United States was
basically Republican which already of a
Republican I'd say but also those the
spirit of reform in the air now had he
become president in 1912 this is the
what-if of history that interested me
it's almost very likely that the United
States might have entered World War one
in 1915 after the sinking of the of the
steamship the Lusitania when a number of
Americans lost their lives it was sunk
by the German submarines during World
War one rules that would have liked to
bring us into the war on the Allied side
has that happened
the war probably would have been over a
good deal earlier because the weight of
the United States was decisive in 1918
and I think it would have been decisive
earlier now he had two more shots of
being friends and ironically had he not
run in 1912 supported Taft even quietly
and reluctantly he almost surely have
got the nomination in 1916 at the end of
Wilson's first term because the man who
did get it a man called Charles Evans
Hughes of the governor of New York and a
Supreme Court justice all but won the
election in 1916 in fact when President
Woodrow Wilson went to bed the night
election night he thought he was beaten
and woke up the next morning to find
that California returns came in and gave
it to him and therefore he edged out
Charles Evans Hughes finally and this I
found perhaps the most interesting of
all Roosevelt having split the Republic
party managed to repair his
relationships he got rid of the
progressives repaired his relationship
by campaigning for Charles Evans Hughes
and then later on when things started
going less well for Wilson it was very
strong critic of Woodrow Wilson's of
policies and a lot of part of the First
World War
almost all historians agree today that
that Theodore Roosevelt would have
gotten the nomination in 1920 and it was
basically almost surely would have won
he died at the relatively early age of
60 years old
in 1919 had Theodore Roosevelt become
president in 1920 a number of things
would have happened which might have
changed the course of 20th century first
of all we would have had a League of
rating of Nations which Wilson espouse
but which Roseville is not opposed to
accepted it would it would have been a
League of Nations with the reservations
that Roosevelt's good friend Henry Cabot
Lodge the chairman of the Republican
chairman of the Senate Foreign Relations
Committee wanted which was basically
very minor of a reservation saying that
the United States Congress should have
the right to declare war just asserting
the power of the Congress it would have
passed with Roosevelt then Roosevelt
would have given the French guaranteed
of France and Britain something which
Wilson again had had offered but the
Versailles tree was voted down because
Wilson would not compromise on these
minor reservations at one point he said
the Senate must take its medicine not a
good way to get something passed by the
United States Senate so that means you
might have had a League of Nations of
military guida France and Britain and
that might have actually prevented the
second rule war let me ask you some more
about these individuals who I know that
Eugene debb's died at age 71 in 1926 who
lived the longest of the four men oh I
think so I think was Taft I'm not
absolutely positive that it was Taft and
how long did Woodrow Wilson lived he
lived to about 1924 think was 1924 me
ask you about health
William Howard Taft you say at one point
was how large it was about 350 pounds
and there's and there's a cup and of
course you can't get away when you think
about Taft about his weight there's two
around a funny story
and the weight one is he had to once be
pried out of the bathtub literally and
there they had to make a special bathtub
for it and secondly when he was serving
under Theodore Roosevelt as
governor-general of Philippines he sent
back a cable to the dead Secretary of
State saying rode horseback for 25 miles
up in the hills never felt better and
the Secretary of State then Lu route
said back a shoe a brief cable to the
Taft the Philippines saying how's the
horse so that was a very difficult thing
that he couldn't get the weight down how
was his health even though he was
hurting not bad despite that enormous
weight not bad at all but you talk about
his wife's health yes his wife's health
was another matter and it says it's a
sad story on him anyway mrs. Taft first
of all was the person who most wanted
William Howard Taft to be President he
as I say was a reluctant present he
didn't want to be President but his he
want to go to the Supreme Court and
twice theaters are offered to him when
Roosevelt was in president twice half
turned it down mainly because of his
wife's pressure and what wife thought he
should become president she didn't like
the Roosevelts
I think she's rather jealous of him
actually so finally of course she gets
her wish in 1980s elected president and
she gets she's 99 she's back and she's
in the white house he's gonna redecorate
it she's going to give a reception she's
gonna it's gonna be her right house her
tone only a few months after the tabs in
the White House mrs. Taft suffered a
straw a severe stroke she could never
really be the hostess that she wanted to
begin she didn't recover from the stroke
I mean she's able to talk and carry on
things but she never had that's the full
force ever again so so her name Helen
Taft I want to read the opening
paragraph of chapter 6 just before an
early dinner at the White House the
president was handed to note from The
Associated Press
reporting Roosevelt's letter to the
governor saying that he would accept the
nomination if offered Taft read the news
without comment and then passed the
piece of paper to others no one spoke as
they sat down to the table until mrs.
Taft broke the silence I told you so
four years ago and you would not believe
me
president laughed quote I know you did
my dear
and I think you are perfectly happy now
you would have preferred the colonel to
come out against me then to have been
wrong yourself what's that all about
well Taft was maybe hidden PEC is the
wrong word but she was he his life as a
bossy woman wasn't an easy woman Taft
was very decent to her and I have no
sense that he had an affair for example
or anything like that but he was
certainly had a tough time with her and
I think he saw it here she would really
rather been right than than anything
else and and aft actually it was exactly
what the author of what he wanted it was
a very jovial decent man as someone once
said of Taft he was a jovial man
surrounded by men who knew exactly what
they wanted he couldn't really handle a
conservative wing of the party back to
health Woodrow Wilson you list three
strokes before the big one 1896 1904
1906 and you say that was the grave one
and then a massive stroke September the
18th 1919 he'd been in President had
been reelected how much did the public
know in 1912 when they went into the
polls way to the polls that he had had
three strokes I don't think they knew it
at all I don't really know what at all
there's no evidence they would and
indeed what's what's shocking is the
massive stroke that he had when he was
campaigning in the West in 1919 in favor
of his Versailles Treaty the death and
his League of Nations the public was not
informed what had happened he was
brought back in a train from Colorado
and the Union to Union Station here in
Washington and then brought to the White
House and then in the bedroom attended
by his personal physician a man called
dr. Carrie Grayson and mrs. Wilson his
said the second mrs. Wilson by the way
is what first wife had died you
remarried and then a really
extraordinary thing happened in this
country there was here was the president
in a bedroom paralyzed and his left side
hardly able to speak he did get somewhat
better as time passed but for the first
couple of months he was really hardly
able to do much to speak a few words and
the country was being run by mrs. Wilson
she
she didn't tell anybody no no one
leveled with the public or nor the
Senate nor the cabinet people suspected
things but they weren't told of an
anything when someone wanted to come in
to see the president
eventually look this person will be a
lug brought into the bedroom the
president will be propped on the side
that was not paralyzed so he could raise
his hands and he could say a few words
by then but the if you if you want to
have a bill sign if she would be the
person who bring it bring it in to him
to have it sign or or say it couldn't be
done she monitored the letters we don't
know what he saw where he didn't say he
then she got somewhat better by the way
he was able to speak eventually more
normally but never very much the same
man go back to the 1906 stroke though
loss of the sight in one eye yeah Ashley
where did he have this what was he doing
then that Frankie confident of exactly
who's president Princeton at the time I
don't know the mone or the stroke
offhand and nobody knew it though when
he ran though nobody know when you ran
that I know of now today could somebody
run and have no sight we had some I said
wasn't yeah it doesn't blind it was it
was it was impaired let's put it that
way but he could see Roosevelt himself
didn't have very good eyesight either
for different reasons I think be almost
impossible today and it would be
impossible for a doctor like his own
doctor to keep this it was it seems to
me that's against any medical ethics the
vice president should have become at
least at the temporary president he
wasn't a very interesting vice president
and Thomas Marshall no men even say well
this country needs a good 5 cent cigar
but nonetheless he was the vice
president and ensure the t-shirt of the
president is shocking business Eugene
debb's of Terre Haute Indiana
his health Deb's was a man who was
constantly over working on one might say
he made speeches all the time for for
the Socialist Party and for his belief
in in that you need a broad-based
industrial Union to cope with the evils
of industrial capitalism he day at night
and so his health was never that good he
would he would exhaust himself too
easily if he'd come down with I don't
know clothes cold coals things of that
it wasn't often it was bedridden for a
while to go off to sanatorium to recover
from just exhaustion as far as we know
that he did lived 1924 so and how many
times he run for president
let's see - I think it was four times
the president and his relationship with
his wife not a was not a warm
relationship
his wife was interesting enough for a
man it was a socialist and I'm very much
a man of the people as Deb's was she was
from a well-to-do family in Terre Haute
Indiana and in one sense she was
marrying someone who's at the time a
rising young man is even doing a little
business said but she had to go along
and with him in his leftist beliefs
eventually and she did she stuck with
him and he never spoke ill of her but he
spent an awful lot of time away from her
and one can't really see that was a
close marriage that had no children
she they ended up living with the
largest I one of the largest houses in
Terre Haute was inheriting little money
she went to visit him in prison once
when his imprisonment after leading the
famous Pullman Strike in 1890s and she
visited in prison with all her jewels
around her neck and pearls and later on
it doesn't come in the book because I
didn't do that much after 1912 and in
details personal life but actually he
himself had a kind of affair himself
later on actually in the in Ramadan
during during the second during the
First World War
even so so it clearly this was not a
long marriage but he never did anything
publicly to break the marriage or than
or anything was ever said openly about
anything in fact appear that a lot of
times his Brotherhood and with someone
running a newspaper which in which he
was a major contributor so he it was not
a war marriage but it was it was
Victorian marriage in a kind of way I
would say when you go when you went back
to that period of time to research it
did you how prominent was the Deb's name
in this country in 1912 and all through
those years when he ran a very prominent
and Deb's was I came to conclude almost
the kind of secular st. you see the
point about Deb's was even if you
disagreed with his socialist views of
the the having basic industries owned by
the state etc
Deb's Deb's gave away of all those money
when you travel I mean go somewhere and
come back he'd have no money left he
just give it to people who needed money
his concern for other people was
profound his identification of the
working class was profound and and above
all he managed to rise above these very
old scholastic kind of debates among the
socials in that time Deb's wasn't
interested in that stuff he kept his
mind on one thing that you had to have a
broad-based union where skilled workers
and unskilled workers being the same
here in those days the American
Federation of Labor which is the main
Union allowed only skilled workers Deb's
wanted everybody be the main Union and
eventually it came to be after his death
with a couple of the CIO which which was
a broad-based union but but Deb's his
reputation was very high in this country
even when people disagreed with him
there's a wonder there's a I can't
resist this wonderful story Deb's
sad and then wonderful I think sad
because he was imprisoned during the
first war by Woodrow Wilson's
administration because he because he
spoke out against the First World War
and it was a there was a thing called
the Espionage Act has been passed with a
Sedition Act and many prominent people
were not social said he should be
pardoned he merely said and Wilson the
very hard man said he would he was the
traitors of the country he'd never be
pardoned in my administration
interestingly enough so he's in prison
in Atlanta Georgia he runs by the way
for president from Atlanta Georgia and
gets it gets almost he gets about saying
our votes he got in 1912 though not as
high a percentage of votes then warren g
harding comes in a Republican president
in 20 in 1920 and he decides that he's
going to bind up a lot of these wounds
that were inflicted by the Wilson
administration domestically and it's
kind of red Honda cetera and he is
exactly pardon but he commutes the
sentence of of G gene dead in Atlanta
and and so he leaves him in Atlanta and
he says to stop off at the White House
on the way home so Deb's gets into the
training and Lana comes up to Union
Station in Washington DC goes over the
White House brought into the
president's office and Harding jumps up
says why mr. dibbs I've heard so much
about you
I'm awfully glad to meet you later on
they asked
Deb how things went he said we
understood each other perfectly and I
think they did understand each other
perfectly but what's the most amount of
votes he ever got close to a million
votes a little over nine hundred
thousand and forty thousand I believe it
was and the health of Theodore Roosevelt
well did all Roosevelt believe very
strongly as almost anybody knows about
his life and realizes in the strenuous
life he was a bore as a boy he was
nearsighted he was sickly asthmatic and
of very much a bookworm too but it was
all twelve years old his father whom he
adored said now you've made your mind
you've got to make your body and so he
he went into a regime of boxing and
gymnastics and then later on went out to
the West and was a rancher almost like a
cowboy he formed a regiment during the
spanish-american war call the Rough
Riders so he always believed in this
strenuous life which was somehow he
thought it was a morally the right thing
to do manly thing to do as he put it and
he after he was president he left the
presidency I should say in nineteen nine
in order not to cast a shadow on Taft
initially he went off to ask her to
shoot wild beasts and so all this was
active he also after the defeat in 1912
he we explored something called the
river of doubt in the Amazon River and
an unexplored part of Brazil where he
all but died I mean it was a disastrous
expedition I mean he thought he was
gonna die at one point that the insects
the the just a general disease was a
miracle he lived and probably wouldn't
if his son was about 2821 at that time
wasn't with him so his he was not in
great health interesting enough just the
strenuous life was all it was too
strenuous so um he he he left the
president at the age of 50 very young
man
and in 1919 I say his he wasn't bad
health he was in bad health again you
know just what he's a people didn't
quite know what it was wrongly chose
rheumatism was when it was the heart it
was one thing of the younger and so it
wasn't good health at all he Pete it's
interesting though you know about was
about and he was in just before he died
was as I say and I think was a January
of 1919 sometime in December when his
health wasn't good but II was getting a
little better it seemed he got up makes
the last public speech he ever made
which is in New York City for a black
radical or William EB Dubois is for the
black veterans and it's quite remarkable
as well that was a man who grew in
office in many many respects he he he
started out as a kind of patrician
reformer and really became a radical
person here or here he became much much
more to espouse black voting in to make
sure that there was a big an
anti-lynching etc so he was he was a man
who grew I think as a as a president we
have over a hundred million people today
that vote in our elections for president
in the United States how many people
roughly voted in the election of 1912
gosh I can't remember I left is it ten
million I mean women could not vote no
women could not vote could blacks vote
then well thought lacks can vote in the
north in the south there were these Jim
Crow laws which effectively presented
the black prevented the blacks from
voting they would have these poll taxes
and a poll tax most poor blacks in the
South Bank times couldn't pay any poll
tax so the black stroke rate and costs
women women were not allowed to vote and
women's suffrage across was a major
issue in this period so that I say I
can't remember the exact about a vote
but certainly in one sense there was a
great deal of many disenfranchised
voters in the United States and in 1912
and this whole period
trying to find out I'm sure I wrote it
down because I know you gave us the
figures maybe I can find it before we're
finished go back to 1912 mm-hmm
these four men like all ran for
president what was the number one thing
on people's mind in 1912 in this country
do you think
I think in 1912 what was happening and
it was was this tremendous spirit of
reform it was free in country and the
thing that people were most troubled by
if I could say the most probably was was
trying to tame the great monopolies
still the monopoly capital capitalism
that wasn't there was a major major
issues to that at that time how do you
deal with the great trusts as they were
called who were they well there were
things like there'd been the Standard
Oil Trust in one point there were there
was a the American Harvester company the
many big companies fault holding
companies within the thing and they
began to and and and they were so large
that they could effectively like any
monopoly of control prices and certainly
they could also decide pretty much about
they want to pay workers badly they
could get away with that too because it
was enough competition so how did you
deal with this growth of industrial
capitalism now these four men had all
grown up in the 19th century and they
were confronted but in the early 20th
century with the growth of industrial
capitalism ins the small businesses
we're not we're being swallowed up at
that point you had a really change and
they didn't mess any what to do they
each had to cope with the best way they
could for Taft his view his way to cope
with it was only through legalism those
business was here to stay and if they do
something wrong will prosecute
Theodore's though took a different view
he thought big business was indeed here
to stay but he really had to be
regulated he was all for regulation and
that was his strong thing they've got to
be regulated Wilson was against the big
monopolies but he want to try to break
the monopolies rather than regulate them
simply regulate them and to do that he
wanted to restore competition his theory
was was rate them and thus restore
competition and that would effectively
do it of course Deb's bigger socialist
believed in in state control of basic
industries and so he he would he would
have caused how the state takeover a lot
of these large trusts but that was the
main issue but I'm riding along with
that issue we're a host of these other
problems which people were very
concerned with in the United States at
that time
there was in fact women's suffrage which
is a very big issue there was child
labor was June you need to be new laws
and child labor employed in these these
places
factory conditions remembers I think was
I think was 1911 was it was a famous
triangle fire when these Shirtwaist
women were made Shirtwaist or the
Shirtwaist Factory in New York were
caught in a fire and couldn't get out
because they had been locked they were
locked in until five o'clock each day or
six o'clock whatever whatever the shift
ended and they ended up I having to jump
out the window and killing and
destroying themselves in this fire was a
terrible terrible business so factory
conditions were appalling
child labor women's suffrage all of
these things were on people's mind and
so the spirit of reform had swept
through this country and therefore three
of the four candidates were strongly
reformist only only caste and even he
was a moderate reformer I would say
moderate reformer but you couldn't be
win if you weren't on the progressive
side you had to be a progressive to get
anywhere
wouldn't election that country this time
I have found the numbers and will put
them on the screen so people can see
them but I'll read them Woodrow Wilson
in 1912 got six million two hundred and
ninety three thousand four hundred and
fifty four votes Theodore Roosevelt
running on the third party progressive
ticket
Bull Moose Party 4 million 119 538 votes
119 thousand Taft William Howard Taft
running on the Republican ticket three
million four hundred and eighty four
thousand nine hundred and eighty and
finally Eugene Debs
nine hundred 1873 but you also point out
that Woodrow Wilson won 40 states 435
electoral college votes to six states
four we mean for Theodore Roosevelt had
eighty eight votes and then only two
states for we M hard Taft
what's that Sadie well it's number
things personal if you if you put the
votes together for then of the
Republicans in the president if you're
assuming that that Dean arose the got
nomination which II was cheated out of
then you then you get a slightly
different figure least in the pocket
well then you get over over seven
million votes you say to Wilson for me
now you can't be this exact because some
people would cross over but once you
look at that it's very hard not to
believe that wrote Roosevelt would have
won one that of course the electoral
vote as we know ourselves doesn't
necessarily reflect the popular vote
after all only four years ago the Al
Gore I had I think off of one by 540
thousand five hundred sixty thousand I
think those votes that's a fair amount
yet lost in the electoral college so
electoral college votes are now somewhat
misleading it was a much closer election
on one level than the electoral vote
shows before we go back to some of these
characters in this book let me ask you
about James Chase where are you from
originally I'm from the Fall River
Massachusetts and how long do you live
there my whole life I was born there my
family came from that part of the world
for one of many generations when did you
get interested in history uh well I'll
tell you a story about that it was in
high school my high in my high school of
American history class and my
grandfather had been the president of
the Massachusetts Senate about it during
this general period around the turn
essentially for quite a number of years
and I'd been told my grandfather died by
the time I was born but I'd always been
told more or less that William Howard
Taft when he was president and stayed at
my grandfather's house which probably
was true or could easily been true so I
wrote a high school paper on William
Howard Taft believe it or not and never
did I dream that that some fifty-four
years later or whatever was that I would
ever write a book which tampered play a
major role but that in a funny but it's
something is strange in life and I
should write a high school paper on tact
and half a century later write a book
which is a major character you still
have the paper I do not have the paper I
which I did do you remember your grade I
think I got a pretty good grade
I got a probably good cut a good wave I
got an A or something like that I guess
the great Fall River Massachusetts to
what college to Harvard College how did
you get in well that guy did well is it
all Bamie in those days was it all based
on you never SATs it was SATs and if
where did you go what was your like I
went in 1949 and they had SAT so but you
had to you had to pick colleges rather
differently because you had to list
three colleges only and they had to be
in order so if you listen to the third
college you might not get in it and or a
nursery my foot was first is Harvard the
second was Cobain third was Brian
get in brown but and they're either a
good time there and I was what you study
well I interesting enough I didn't study
history and politics as you might
imagine my life took the grades of
mature I was very literary in that in
that period I was the editor of the
Lehrer magazine at Harvard called the
Harvard advocate and I majored in French
and Italian literature and I'll tell you
how I became in politics so if you'd
like to know after I got out of college
I got a I got a fellowship to go to
Paris to study well French literature
actually Baudelaire the poet Baudelaire
and a painter and a la cuarta I went
there and this is 1954 and that year was
the year in which the French lost
Indochina it was very hard to be an
American boy in France and not become
political it was it would have been like
a French boy in the United States in
1968 say you got some problems here and
then I went I was then draft in the army
the year after that I got when I got
back and I was sent back to France in
the Army it's just as a private and when
I got but only because my name began
would see if the army didn't look much
else but when I got there like my basis
is ollie on they look and slow they saw
that I actually knew French so they sent
me the French army firfer for two years
of the kind of translator and an
interpreter and I was said to Verdun
which is a famous place the first world
war with the French held out against the
Germans so that was the period of the
Algerian war so by the time I'd come
back I was very very politicized
interesting enough that really was a
period and I also began to see something
which was not fashionable United States
I saw the connection between what I call
art and politics it was a time when
Albert Camus was writing his his his
famous books Sartre was let writing
jean-paul Sartre was writing plays see
Lyon de Beauvoir was was in fact it was
a very active period in French
literature on the theatre and it was
about being what the French called on
gosh a to be engaged and so I came back
I I my life changed again
studying here and I died yet so even
even in France I did some studies and
politics in my life
my life took a completely different
cause all because of those three years
in France I don't know if it would have
happened otherwise so did you ever work
in politics
well not per se but I spent my life in
politics for saying but I spent my life
in foreign policy I got that and worked
on magazines which we devoted to foreign
policy my whole life until about ten
years ago when I started teaching at
Bard College who owns foreign affairs
magazine the Council on Foreign
Relations how long were you the managing
editor thirteen years
so that's your that's the core of your
profession as a court my profession
before that I had founded a magazine
called into play which was a US European
relations earlier than that I worked for
a I think called East Europe magazine
about East European politics and later
on after I left Foreign Affairs have to
bring briefly the New York Times as an
international affairs editor in the book
review I then went to I was then off for
this job at bar I've chaired a very nice
chair national relations at bar in
college and at the same time somehow as
I was off the editorship for magazine
called the world policy journal so
between I was really my life has been as
an editor
primarily and and completely involved in
foreign affairs and all the most all the
books I read most of them have got to do
with in to do with Foreign Affairs
you're the Paul W Williams professor of
government and public law at Bard
College mr. Peck who was Paul Williams
and what is Bard College well Bob
Williams was it was a well-known alumnus
who left a big little money defer to
endow a chair and was interested
obviously in such things as government a
bar is a small liberal arts college at
Hudson on the Hudson River about two
hours from New York and it's a wonderful
school it's a wonderful school about to
maybe about 1,200 1,300 students and
it's outside sizes worth more and it
always been known as a very much as an
art school for a long time but in the
last 10-15 years under a really quite
brilliant president called Leon Botstein
a very invented man brilliant educator
Barnes been attracting students from all
over the country who are interested in
things like like politics and things the
Foreign Affairs in fact it's very
interesting but at the moment at Bard
the largest number of students studying
in the
whether we call the social studies are
in the Power and Political Studies
department right now which is player to
change for the old bar and and there's
still a lot of art students but there's
a definite interest in politics there
and it's been some very good people
teach there it's a very rewarding place
there is good to teach I like it a lot
and I like teaching a lot just around
the time we're taping this and I
mentioned this TV where we started there
is a big story about Yale doctor giving
a speech at Hofstra University and
accusing the president announced eight I
think of lying and a number of other
things around the Iraq war and a big
story was made out of the New York Times
and everybody started writing it up but
I noticed when I got on the website the
same day at Bard College Robert Redford
gave basically some of the same comments
about the accusing American of lying
about Iraq and nobody made anything out
of it what's the reason well it's a it's
a isn't that it probably the student
body of Bard is very liberal school left
at the liberal student body quite
frankly I didn't I was unable to go to
graduation this year but went but I
asked him about it and it did you should
miss it people will have to graduate to
it he never mentioned that part all I
said well he talked a lot about an
environment so we should get out the
vote so so that that that didn't have
that kind of impact that was of hor-aha
of horrifying people doesn't mean a lot
of people who are also more someone more
conservative it Bart some students they
are need well the reason I ask is that
if Bart is somewhat of a liberal school
Woodrow Wilson William Howard Taft
Theodore Roosevelt Eugene Debs
came there today and what you know or
maybe came there years ago who would
they like and why well they said he
would like Deb's for one thing first of
all you've left her than anything about
deficits you he his I could do the
gesture though he was a just a trifle
speaker and they probably liked Theodore
Roosevelt next who also was a powerful
speaker while it's true that Wilson is
an eloquent man the energy that Deb's
and Roosevelt put in it was so powerful
and so strong and probably Wilson will
be third and Taft would definitely be
the bottom two least popular for also is
the Ford man was not a very good speaker
either so we go back to 1912 and maybe
1911 or what let me go through the four
although we know a lot more about gene
devs cuz he'd been running
in night in the 1912 election when did
Woodrow Wilson decide
he'd been Governor of New Jersey he had
been present in Princeton when did he
decide that's a very interesting
question what happened Wilson first of
all
Wilson was had always been interested I
think he's on the heart of hearts as a
boy probably as a young man I'd love to
be President someday but the best way to
become president is not usually going to
university after all so he anyway he
ends up as a as a teacher a successful
scholar comes President of Princeton at
Princeton initially he's very very
popular and successful president he
wants to he instituted a system at
Princeton we had tutorials and students
and he wants to break up what he
considered the sort of fraternity club
system of Princeton but then he but he's
unable to do that doesn't handle it very
well he's a stubborn man Wilson doesn't
do very well at that that and then he
also is a big fight about where the
Graduate Center is gonna go the
important thing about that only is that
again Wilson was unable to compromise so
after the s having a beginning a rather
successful presidency with these
tutorials and things he ends up now
being rather unhappy at Princeton by
1910 1911 now let's go to New Jersey
politics the journey of politics was run
by a bunch of bosses and they were
considered the Democrats as well as
Republicans and bosses and was rampant
that was another thing by the way I
should mention the people were very fed
up would they want to break the bosses
they could anyway you had by with who or
some of the bosses in 1919 oh well it
was true New York the famous famous one
it was Charlie Murphy of Tammany Hall
which is a famous Boston indeed and a
man called new jet was over in New
Jersey Jim Smith a number of them what
happened any case was that the bosses
were looking around for somebody that
they could run for governor and they
said their reputation was fairly shady
because of payoffs and things were also
going on these people they think think
they came upon Woodrow Wilson they
thought he's an honorable man he's
honest and he's a conservative
Republican emic rat which they were they
weren't you know they were they were
they were they were dead to a certain
degree they they did a lot of things
good things for poor people but they
also
want the unions to be too powerful
either than they off because they would
often working very closely with big
businesses to keep everything quiet so
they go for Wilson and he is a
conservative Democrat he's a southerner
he was frankly a white supremacist he
had also written in a history the
American people published the early
night in early 20th century a number of
things he said hostile to the new
immigration a new immigration that food
was a lot coming from Central Europe and
Italy so he was seen as a conservative
man and they thought he be he would be
safe and and and because he was honest
in one thing not so they they they put
him in a puttin they getting the
nomination and then much to their
astonishment that he turns on and in
fact before he got the nomination once
they'd be the nominee he campaigns on
much more liberal much more progressive
like overnight he becomes a progressive
as Wilson realized whatever he may have
personally thought initially that you
couldn't really win that easily if you
weren't progressive of this friend the
bosses were behind the time they were
fighting these a lot of the reforms so
Wilson ran as a reformer and then when
he was elected governor the the the boss
who thought that he was just using a lot
of rhetoric and that really he would
play ball in he turns on the bosses and
and and through and and from various
machinations gets to gets rid of them as
well so he is now a a full-fledged
reformer and progressive he taps a lot
of the policies in other words the
Roosevelt had been talking about 1910
and 1911 and no long he considered quote
conservative Democrat though he still
remains to be frankly a white
supremacist the the Democratic Party
therefore season will turn out where
this man has been successful in New
Jersey was very successful governor pass
some good progressive legislation and so
when they're not when the candidates a
look at they're looking at candidates in
1912 1912 in really of course it comes
down to really the three people are an
important the party one of course is
this new governor of New Jersey who has
a good reputation the second is William
Jennings Bryan we're also run for
president
a couple of times for the he was a for
the Democratic body he was a populist an
old-fashioned populist a liberal man but
not really as much in touch with it with
the current mood of reform probably he
even his voters come from small towns
from a lot of farmer farmers not as much
from the from the urban working classes
is becoming a much bigger fact and will
become a big factor for the Democratic
Party to get but get so but Brian would
love to see the nomination go to him yet
again having had it twice before and
then a man called champ Clark who was
the the the the speaker in 1910 he
because of the Democratic Speaker of the
House and he's a moderate reformer and a
good party man so with by no means a
given that Wilson was going to get this
nomination and then it came this famous
convention in Baltimore which went for
46 ballots and Wilson was not leading
for a very long time and at one point
during the midst of the convention he
thought he's gonna lose and and and to
put on the phone he was in his house in
Princeton and called his campaign man he
said look withdraw my name I'm not gonna
get this thing and then they another
another another one of the other
managers got on the phone and said
listen governor don't withdraw it's not
over yet and part of the reason that he
got things because we and Jennings Bryan
was maneuvering between champ Clark and
Woodrow Wilson saying because he still
was a powerful figure in the party and
and secretly of course Bryan wanted to
get the nomination again thought if he
could sort of deadlock the party that
would happen but it turned out that
finally through some machinations Wilson
got it I want to read you back what you
wrote about a man named William McCombs
a member and yeah sure McCombs Moody and
hypersensitive reacted to Wilson's
response to Bryan by escaping to a
friend's house in Baltimore tumult II
learned afterwards where quote he was
found in a room lying across the bed
crying miserably unquote to his friends
who asked what was the matter
McCombs replied weeping that the
governor had spoiled everything by his
telegram to Bryan that had the governor
followed his McCombs advice he could
have been nominated I read it only
that I've heard of many grown men
involved in political campaigns crying
over something like well in McComas was
it was it was it was it was a weepy man
and a very nervous person not a very
strong figure and what he was doing was
matter is that he Wilson refused to play
ball with the bosses of New York because
McCombs was trying to make a deal with
with Charlie Murphy of the Tammany
people to get this nomination and Wilson
would not do this you see and so that
that's that's about that statement but
the but he wasn't he wasn't a very
ineffective person indeed the other
person man called McAdoo was much
stronger and later and he was a person
who really stiffened Wilson's I think
it's good I had a Roosevelt for a moment
and kind of the same thing when he had
been president after the assassination
of William McKinley in 1901 if he then
was elected in 1904 mm-hmm
1908 as you said earlier he passed it to
William Howard Taft
this is 1912 election when did he decide
to go against his friend William Arthur
it's a very good question
and it's interesting one first of all in
19 for Roosevelt made a really fatal
error in the campaign he didn't have to
lose in campaign said and I'm not gonna
run for a third term because in those
days as we all know you could run for
there was no term limitation Franken
Rose electro around four turns in war he
couldn't have no man could have
regretted more than that remark that he
made later but he also but Rose was a
man of honor and he felt he couldn't go
back on that at least definitely
believed so he couldn't run for third
term and he's gonna put in his his his
friend Taft would carry things out and
he goes off as I think early to Africa
to shoot wild beasts and also not to
pass the shadow on Taft
but while he's in Africa beans to get
letters from his old cronies for various
reason saying the Taft is is not
carrying out his policies for
effectively particularly issues of
conservation since Roosevelt more than
any other president to you know save
millions and millions of acres in the
United States from being you know
destroyed by buy bought by large
companies the park system is really
large Park in Yellowstone all those big
part of leader Farrell Roosevelt in any
case so he gets these very disturbed by
this he comes back to back to the United
States he still this time
good friends and he's disturbed by
what's happening so so but he's not
prepared when he gets back to uh run it
and run for president or order or do
anything but actually campaigns the Taft
even if rather quietly it's you can't
put your finger on it exactly how was
going on his mind but sometime by but
the nine nine nineteen eleven a
combination of two things I think first
of all his genuine disenchantment with
taps ability to character kept being the
hands when he called it the arch
conservators of the party what she was
and then secondly I think there was
power
Roosevelt miss power and he wanted that
power back again and the interesting
thing about power in his case powerful
for Theodore Roosevelt tended to be a
disciplinarian thing what I mean by that
is when Roosevelt was out of power he
would often say outrageous things when
in power she was much more moderate it
rather imperialist before he became
president but when he was president
except for the Panama Canal which you
can consider let's move one wants to he
really moved away from that got the
Nobel Peace Prize and it was in nineteen
nineteen six six Nobel Peace Prize for
for mediating the Russell Japanese war
so that was this this so that as a
foreign policy person in one of the
United States to play a great role in
the world but but he moved away from the
imperialist thing he thought if he must
want to be a power so in short I think a
combination of his disenchantment with
Taft and then his desire that he could
do it better you know what I mean just
missed that and I think that's that's
what happened we don't have a lot of
time so I don't want you to go into
great deal on this because you've got
other things I want to ask you about but
at the Republican convention in nineteen
twelve where was it held it was held in
Chicago and who won and and then well it
was it was Taft Taft got the kid got the
nomination away from from Roosevelt
because the these delegates at Rosalind
gotten in the primaries were
disqualified by the chairman of the
convention who'd been at all who'd been
Roosevelt Secretary of State by the way
but ele root but Roosevelt but he they
were determined to keep the party
machineries was they were not gonna let
Roosevelt take it away
where did they have the Progressive
Party convention and what happened there
well that also happened in Chicago very
shortly after right at the same place
a kind of it wasn't they don't have the
conventional you eat related but there
was a mass meeting after Roosevelt had
lost this and marched out wasn't I get
the nomination of progressives then said
that to get Roosevelt to run for
president and he said famously at that
time we stand at Armageddon to do battle
for the Lord it was a very very full are
firmly I party Jane Addams the famous
reform and women's suffrage suffragettes
second it rose those nomination at the
at the actual convention which came a
few weeks later so I don't have my hands
on the quotes but is it safe to assume
that Theodore Roosevelt said things
about William Howard Taft that were
stronger and more outspoken than
anything we hear today about any of
these candidates that in his party's
absolutely I mean absolutely called him
a puzzle where he called him all sorts
of things you know and he was his friend
and he's not any been his friend he'd
been in straight across they would they
became very very apart although I wanted
men to make a play that there later on
you know by nineteen doing the second
during the first world war they had one
person coming here against mrs. Wilson
and they became friends again and I want
to say one thing was very touching to me
they became friends and in a hotel room
in Chicago they and they saw each other
and dining dining rooms are the dining
room and then Roosevelt said to Taft
will you've got to come see me now and
at Sagamore Hill which is Roosevelt's
how home in law and a few weeks and and
Taft was very pleased that they both
work there they were could be friends
again and Roosevelt died forged iron
over and at the funeral tacticals went
to the funeral and afterwards to the
graveside and after the graveside people
left there the last person to leave the
great side was William Howard Taft
weeping there's another story that you
do it we've talked about it on this
program before but you go into more
detail and then I've seen before and I
be interested where you got it on the
famous John Schrank attempted
assassination of Theodore Roosevelt in
Milwaukee it was just amazing it's it's
one of most extraordinary stories of
Roosevelt's strength and determination
Roosevelt as we all know in those days
particularly there's a lot of stem
winding speeches and whistle stopping
across the country Roosevelt's in
Milwaukee
he's doing the hotel he's supposed to
get his speech downtown coming out of
the hotel lobby walked into a into an
open car and gets in the automobile and
at that point a man comes out of out of
the crowd and shoots him and wounds him
did you say he was standing in the car
was he standing I think was standing
like he was standing the cop he fell
over back like that and those it goes
and and and it it goes right into his
chest the reason he lived at all was
because he had a 50-page speech in his
inside pocket because it was not
uncommon to give long long speeches in
those days well of course it's a doctor
or the people a security people
apprehend for they had scared to
apprehend immediately the attempted
assassin assassin but Roosevelt he said
I'm gonna go and make that speech which
they were sort of horrified and he just
insist I'm gonna go and so is so they
looked in studies to start they do they
can really wound he goes down and down
to this hall filled with about 10,000
people gets up on the stage the opens
his shirt to show the show that his his
that the blood all on the inside of the
shirt these things say it takes more
than a bullet to kill a bull moose
because the progressives that time were
known as a bull moose campaign and he
goes on for 50 minutes for 50 minutes
with a bullet lodged in his ribs to make
this extraordinary speech and then after
that goes to hospital for two weeks
during which time everybody
all the other candidates ceased
campaigning except for Wilson gives a
few speeches
did they ever take the bullet out yeah
no none of it they did there was another
quote I know because we just have a
minute ago you wrote the book on a book
on Dean Acheson but in the book this is
a small matter Louis Brandeis he turned
out to go he went
Wilson put him on the Supreme Court but
you talk about Atchison clerking for
Brandeis but more interesting about how
Brandeis anonymously wrote articles in
support of Wilson in Colliers magazine
explain that that's right
well and what happened yeah Louis
Brandeis RIS law was at the time of 1912
was a very successfully brilliant lawyer
in Boston a Wilson didn't know him but
he was introduced to Brandeis and Lucy
Wilson didn't quite have an idea of how
the counter Roosevelt's theories of
regulating the monopolist so how was
gonna come up we didn't really know
didn't have a good idea but Brandeis
gave him this idea and he said look it's
all about competition small businesses
and this is what he was talking about
competition was talking about this kind
of new freedom and he began writing
these these articles and those sorts of
speeches and things like that and so he
so Wilson was indebted to to to Brandeis
as his core ideas of competitiveness and
the so called we called a new freedom
when I became president and she pointed
Brandeis and he was the first Jew who
was appointed to the Supreme Court which
was was with something to do in those
days as you know and Brandeis became of
course one of the most distinguished
jurors in the history of the Supreme
Court again though reading what brand I
stood for back then and what would he be
today do you think ah well you know
Brandeis Brandeis was a person who
believed as did as did Oliver Wendell
Holmes other favors those who are the
dissenters at that time that it was
important to go along with what the
Congress wanted it and and if in other
words if the Congress wants to have the
kind of things that Wilson wants to pass
that's that's what the court should
support in other words that they're very
leery of overruling what they felt so
he'd be on Antonin Scalia sorry well I
think that's an extreme remark I don't
think he would have been quite as
concerned Scalia it's that we talk about
concerns and liberals in a very odd way
that wouldn't save in that school there
wasn't me for competition well very much
for copies at that time but at that time
that would that would have been a very
liberal point of view because of the
fact that you have monopoly so you try
to break monopolies so things change in
that way well here's the cover of the
book our guest has been James Chase he's
a professor at Bard College here is 1912
Wilson Roosevelt Taft and Debs the
election that changed the country thank
you very much
thank you